Let's consider a
collision in a lab frame
in which one
particle is coming in
and the other
particle is at rest.
So here's particle 2.
V2 initial is 0.
And we could say
that m2 is twice m1.
And this is our lab frame.
And now let's consider
the same collision
in the center of mass frame.
And in that reference
frame, we have
particle 1 moving with
velocity V1 prime initial
and particle 2 moving with
velocity V2 initial prime.
Now, the way we're going
to analyze this problem
is that we know the speeds
in the center of mass frame
relative to the lab frame.
So we actually know
these initial speeds.
And we'll write that
result down in a moment.
Because we know
the initial speeds,
we also know that V1 final
in the center of mass frame
is just minus the
initial velocity.
That's the beauty of the
center of mass frame.
The velocities just
change direction.
They don't change magnitude.
Because we know this
we can get V1 final.
And then it's just
a simple exercise
to go back to the lab
frame to calculate
the quantity, the velocity of
the object 1 in the lab frame.
So that will be our
sequence of ideas.
And the key fact that
we know is that V1 prime
is equal initially to
the reduced mass divided
by m1 times V1, 2,
where V1, 2 initial
is just equal to
V1 initial minus 0.
So that's V1 initial.
And the ratio, mu over m1, it's
very simple to calculate that.
That's just m2 over m1 plus
m2, or our case, that's 2/3.
And so from our result,
we now have very simply
that V1 final prime is
minus V1 initial prime.
So it's minus 2/3 V1 initial.
And that's a very
straightforward calculation.
We can do exactly the same
thing with V2 final prime.
V2 final prime is
minus V2 initial prime.
And V2 initial prime is equal
to minus mu over m2 times V1, 2
initial.
This ratio instead of being
2/3, it's a simple exercise.
It will be m1 over m1
plus m2 is 1/3 V1 initial.
And so we have solved for the
final velocities in the center
of mass reference frame.
Now let's just double
check our results.
We have V2 final is
minus V2 initial.
So that's minus.
But there's another
minus sign here.
So we have 2 minus signs.
So that's a plus.
And that's why we have
a plus 1/3 V1 initial.
And finally, if we want
to ask the question, what
are the velocities
in the lab frame,
it's now a very simple exercise
to do reference frame change.
We do need to know what
V center of mass is.
That's V1 V initial over m1
plus m2, because remember
that V2 initial is 0.
So that's another
factor, V1 initial.
And now for conclusion, we
have that the final velocity
in the lab frame is
equal to the velocity
in the center of mass frame
plus V center of mass.
And we just collect our
results, minus 2/3 V1
initial plus 1/3 V1 initial.
So that's minus 1/3 V1 initial.
The outgoing velocity of
particle 1 in the lab frame
and the outgoing velocity of
particle 2 in the lab frame,
again, we have 1/3 V1 initial
plus another 1/3 V1 initial
is equal to 2/3 V1 initial.
So we were able to solve this
problem by switching reference
frame using our basic fact
in the center of mass frame
that the speeds remain the
same but the direction changes
and able to solve this
problem without any
of the traditional ways of
applying the energy momentum
relationship and kinetic energy
or having quadratic equations.